If you want to hear my theory about how one
of these characters could be back in a future
installment of Saw, then stick around to the
end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
Visit audible.com/czsworld to get started
and get your first audiobook for free.
One of the most interesting things about the
Saw franchise is that nobody is ever portrayed
without major flaws, even among the so called
good guys.
There is perhaps no better example of this
than the father and son pair: Eric and Daniel
Matthews.
Welcome to Horror History, my name is Deathbelle
Delphine and I will be your instructor today
as we cover Eric and Daniel Matthews.
This father and son first appeared in Saw
II, but their story stretches back much further
than that.
So let’s take it back.
Eric Matthews was born in the late 60s or
early 70s.
He would become a homicide detective for the
Metropolitan Police Department known for his
uncompromising attitude, where he was well
respected earlier in his career, but his crumbling
home life eventually seeped into his job.
He had trouble in his marriage sometime after
he and his wife gave birth to their son,
Daniel, in the early 90s.
Though the first cause of his marital troubles
are not known, it was likely that Eric’s
infidelity was the final straw before his
wife filed for divorce.
In 2000, these home issues had begun to manifest
themselves in his work life.
The first known incident happened when he
broke a suspect’s jaw with his flashlight.
He has also been criticized for gunning down
an unarmed suspect and planting evidence on
criminals in order to get an easier conviction.
It was around 2003 when Eric had an affair
with his female partner, Allison Kerry.
Not only did he lose his marriage because
of this, but he also stopped working with
Ms. Kerry and lost custody of his son, who
was entering his teenage years.
Daniel began acting out, and I think it was
because his father was a cop that he chose
a life of petty crime to get back at him.
The seriousness of these crimes rode the line
of a punishable offense, so Daniel managed
to stay out of juvy.
In 2005, while still in the process of getting
the divorce, the media caught wind of Eric’s
foul… wind.
*laughter*
That sounds nasty.
A KCUD 2 news crew confronted him one night
about rumors of police brutality, causing
Eric to snap.
“... use brutality against suspects.”
“What brutality?
Let me tell you something!
What brutality?
Huh?
WHAT?
Where’s my cigarette?”
Not only was Matthews suspended for excessive
use of force and implicated in evidence tampering,
but the news footage appeared in a TV documentary,
and only worsened his already waning reputation.
If we take a look at the meltdown meter, he
was basically at the level of Elle Mills.
"This is all I ever wanted.
And why the **** am I so ****ing unhappy?
This... it doesn't make any ****ing sense."
Eric never really got back into the field
after his suspension, instead opting to take
desk work and causing follow of his fellow
cops to question his dedication to the job.
That would change, however, when the other
side of the law made things more personal.
In October of 2005, Eric received a call that
his son had been caught shoplifting at a store
called Superior Electronics.
He picks him up and is unable to get through
to him, they just end up arguing.
It was Eric’s turn to be in charge of the
kid, but Daniel decides he’d like to go
back to his Mom’s house early, and he storms
off without saying goodbye.
Daniel never makes hit back to his mother’s
house though, he is abducted by a man named
Obi, who is working for a criminal who is
just starting to pick up some notoriety in
the city, a man only known to the public as
Jigsaw.
When Daniel wakes up, he finds himself in
a room with seven other criminals and notices
they are being recorded by a video camera.
The last to wake up is a woman named Amanda,
who finds a key with a hidden tape recorder
that tells them they are breathing in a deadly
nerve gas that would kill them in two hours,
but the doors to the house would not open
until three hours had elapsed.
They are tasked with finding the antidotes
hidden around the house.
A couple clues are given.
“One is inside the safe in front of you.
You all possess the combination to the safe.
Think hard.
The numbers are in the back of your mind.
The clue to their order can be found over
the rainbow.”
He also tells them to think about what they
have in common, and, as usual, X marks the
spot.
“You are a pirate!”
So, in true pirate fashion, the first guy
to try to escape gets his face blown off,
leaving Daniel and the others to scavenge
the halls of the Nerve Gas House for more
clues, and before you type your comment telling
me to look for clues, yes, I am aware I look
like Shaggy.
Get over it!
"I'm fixing me a super Shaggy sandwich!"
Now the reason Daniel is being tested is not
specifically stated.
It could be for not appreciating his time
with his father, who really just has the kid’s
best interests in mind... but it’s probably
because he is veering off into a life of crime,
because part of what they all have in common
is that they’ve committed crimes, even if
the ones Daniel committed are much less severe
than the others.
Many of the victims who make it out of the
victims who come out of Jigsaw’s traps are
rehabilitated, and begin to cherish their
lives after they recover.
Daniel is probably one of the best examples
where you can see him changing in real time
as he watches the big guy, Xavier, trying
to smash down a door.
You can see Daniel flinching with each and
every hit.
With each strike Xavier pounds into the door,
he’s also pounding the picture of how scary
life in prison can be into the teenager’s
head.
Another thing to note about this scene is
that Daniel is the calmest person out the
group, and perhaps the reason he is able to
last longer in the Nerve Gas House than any
of the others is because he isn’t doing
as much heavy breathing.
Also, Jigsaw doesn’t typically test kids,
though I would love to one of those spin-off
series’ where it would basically be called
Saw Babies or some ****.
But despite perhaps being in less danger early
on in this game, the others would soon make
a discovery that made Daniel Matthews the
biggest target of all.
Jigsaw, the evil mastermind of the Saw franchise,
managed to outsmart his opponents with his
razor sharp intellect.
But what if the opposition had been a little
bit smarter?
If only they knew about Audible.
Audible is the leading provider of spoken
word entertainment and audiobooks.
Twenty-seven percent of adults haven't read
a single book in the last year, and the main
reason is lack of time.
But with Audible, you don't need to find time,
because you can just listen to the audiobooks,
whether they're about engineering, human psychology,
or just straight up entertainment.
You can listen to stuff while you're out shopping,
while you're at the gym, gardening, or just
to kill time if you can't do any of those
things cause you're locked in a quarantine!
Right now I'm checking out Misery, one of
the most beloved books by our boy Stephen
King.
I've always enjoyed the movie, but I've just
never had the time to pick up the book.
And who would want to pick up a book?
I mean... it could be contaminated.
See, John Kramer was definitely on to something
when he made all those tapes for his victims.
"I want to play an audiobook."
Well John, all you have to do is head on over
to audible.com/czsworld, or text czsworld
to 500-500.
That will give you the option to start a 30-day
free trial, which includes a free audiobook
that you get to keep no matter what.
Once again, that's audible.com/czsworld, you'll
find that link in the description, or text
czsworld to 500-500.
After one of the women, Laura, finds a secret
basement, Daniel joins the group to investigate,
and they find a mannequin with a note for
Obi, explaining the rules of his furnace trap,
where he was unsuccessful in obtaining 2 antidotes.
Laura starts getting woozy after this and
Daniel encourages her not to stop and rest.
He offers her a sense of optimism which shows
Jigsaw that the way he behaves with his dad
really is just a result of him lashing out
and he is genuinely a good kid.
Daniel asks Amanda why she was chosen for
the game, and she tells of how she was a junkie
who was once framed for possession, but Daniel
does not yet know that it was really his father
who put her behind bars.
That’s gonna be an AWKWARD CONVERSATION
if it ever comes up.
…
One of the other guys comes to let them know
they found an unlocked door, and Daniel displays
his kind heart once again by helping the deteriorating
Laura down the stairs.
The next game is for Xavier, but he selfishly
throws Amanda into the pit instead, which
Daniel bravely helps her climb out of, even
in the shadow of Xavier’s deteriorating
sanity.
As they search for the next room, the group
tries to figure out one of Jigsaw’s clues
by determining what it is that they all have
in common.
The only shared thread seems to be that all
of them have been to jail… of of them, except
Daniel.
But as it turns out...
Daniel is the very reason that each of them
are linked.
The reason is unveiled when Laura finds the
X.
X marks the spot.
“You are a--
Shut up, that meme is outdated!
The X marks the spot of a photograph proving
that Daniel is the son of Eric and each of
these criminals clearly remembers Eric Matthews
as the man who framed them and got them locked
up, so they aren’t too happy with the whole
Matthews family in general.
To be fair though, they still all did commit
crimes, they just weren’t the same crimes
that each of them was imprisoned for.
And to be honest, it’s not like the teenager
Daniel really has any control over the actions
of his father.
So maybe they don’t have to be upset with
--
"OPEN THE ****ING DOOR!!"
Nope, they’re still mad.
Laura didn’t last long after that. Xavier
goes off on his own and begins hunting down
the others, so Amanda takes Daniel under her
wing.
They barricade themselves back in the original
room and discover a trap door under the safe.
Big brain Daniel is the one to to remember
that when Amanda originally found the tape
recorder, there was a key alongside it, and
that key is good to unlock the trap door and
gain access to the basement.
At this point Xavier has picked off all the
others, and he chases after them in an effort
to collect the numbers shaved into the back
of each of their heads.
Remember the clue: the numbers are in the
back of your mind.
Eventually they make it to the bathroom, where
Daniel does what Adam did in that very same
room one year earlier and plays dead, in order
to gain the upper hand with a surprise attack
on Xavier.
So yeah.
Daniel kills a man at age 14 or however old
he is.
Let’s give it up for Daniel for being a
bad***.
Don’t even type “F” in the comments
for Xavier, let’s just get a big fat BRUH
in the chat for Daniel.
What a little trooper.
With that, the game is over.
Daniel’s health is dangerously low, so Amanda
gives him the heart container…
I mean a dose of the antidote to get him through
until the doors open.
We don’t actually see this happen, but I’m
assuming that’s what goes down, because
the needle can be found later on.
Amanda helps Daniel get to safety by transporting
him to Jigsaw’s workshop at the Wilson Steel
Plant, where he’s given an oxygen mask and
stowed away in a safe.
I’m guessing the oxygen mask was both to
help him clear the nerve gas from his system
and to keep him breathing in the tiny airspace
of the safe, where he would stay until the
following day.
Later that afternoon, Eric is feeling apologetic
about the argument he had with his son, and
tries to ahold of him, but is obviously unsuccessful.
His former partner and mistress Alison Kerry
calls him in to the case of a murder, and
the victim is a man named Michael Marks, an
informant that Matthews has used in the past.
Upon arriving at the crime scene, Matthews
is dismissive.
Even though this is someone that he knows,
he doesn’t seem to care a whole lot.
I think this is because his head isn’t in
the moment.
He’s thinking about his relationship with
his son.
He’s distracted by the pressure of his wife’s
lawyers.
And being around Kerry probably reminds him
of his biggest mistake.
(Or at least what he thinks is his biggest
mistake at that point.)
It’s not until Kerry points it out that
he notices that Jigsaw has left him a little
message.
Roll it.
"Look closer Detective Matthews."
"At what?"
"Ask whoever wrote it."
Kerry spends the rest of that day trying to
bring him onto the Jigsaw case, but Eric can’t
be bothered with it, telling her about all
the other stresses he’s dealing with.
Still, the images of the crime scene stuck
in his head that night until he eventually
has an epiphany.
The steel used in the trap reminded him of
a case from his past at the Wilson Steel Plant.
The next day he finally gets out of the office
and turns up in person for the SWAT raid at
Wilson Steel.
Thinking he has gotten the upper hand against
Jigsaw he leans in close, and asks,
“Is this close enough?”
This line demonstrates Mathews’ obsession
with power, which is one of the reasons that
he’s in the mess he’s in in the first
place.
He can’t just catch Jigsaw, he has to gloat
over him, but little does he know, the battle
has only just begun.
Unlike the previous criminals he was able
to frame, arrest, and drop easy convictions
on, Eric Matthews had finally met his match
with Jigsaw.
Matthews’s men are about to take John Kramer
away, but John tells him he’ll need to remain
in place while Eric deals with a problem in
the other room, a series of monitors showing
the events of the game in the Nerve Gas House.
Eric doesn’t recognise the other criminals
that he'd put away over the years, but he
does recognize his son, so he confronts Jigsaw
in a rage.
John simply asks Eric for some of his time
for a one on one talk, and promises if he
can do that he’ll get his son back.
“You’ll find your son in a safe and secure
state.”
Is that a little pun from Jigsaw?
Because Daniel's in a safe; literally, in
a safe?
His first instinct is to attack Jigsaw.
Again, this tells us a lot about Matthews,
even without seeing much of his past in the
canon.
Psychologists often use a person’s first
reaction to make an analysis about them, that’s
why those Rorschach tests are helpful to make
a diagnosis.
Showing Eric Matthews his son in danger is
essentially Jigsaw’s Rorschach test.
When Eric threatens violence, John reminds
him that he’s already got cancer, so hand
to hand violence seems pretty insignificant
to him.
Jigsaw’s game is simply to test Eric’s
restraint.
If he could sit there and talk to the man
that was responsible for his son’s kidnapping,
he would pass.
But if he resorted to dirty tactics, like
he did to arrest the other criminals who had
been in the Nerve Gas House and the other
victims of his police brutality, he would
be punished.
Matthews is quickly losing his patience though,
so Kerry tries to get him to take a logical
approach by threatening to destroy the blueprints
of Jigsaw’s traps, but when Matthews puts
this into practice he takes the big, angry,
create a spectacle approach, which is no match
for John’s cool, casual, intelligent tactics.
“How will you get your conviction without
all of this evidence, Eric?”
The difference in Matthews approach and what
Kerry had in mind is symbolic of the difference
between a good cop and a dirty cop, as well
as the difference between someone who has
studied Jigsaw and understands him versus
someone who has actively avoided what would
become the biggest case the city has ever
seen.
John’s intention is to tactfully point this
out and make Eric realize the error of his
ways, so as a clue, he tells him to look inside
of a drawer in the other room, which contains
the arrest files of everyone in the game.
Unfortunately for Eric, he still doesn’t
get the point, and when he notices Xavier
going after Daniel and Amanda on the monitors,
he loses control, and goes full Bashurverse
on the Meltdown Meter.
“You ****ing win okay!?
I'll ****ing go!
I’LL GOOOO!!!”
He goes into the room with John alone, beats
him up and breaks his finger.
He breaks the walkie-talkie in what I see
as an attempt to communicate to John that
he no longer wishes to play by the rules,
if brutality is what it takes, Eric is more
than willing to go there.
When he sticks his gun in John’s mouth,
John has seen enough.
“Game over.”
He offers to take him to the house where the
game was held.
If Eric had just held on and done things by
the book for a little bit longer he would
see that the game on the screens is already
over and his son is tucked away safely.
When they arrive at the house, John gives
Eric a key, which he uses to storm in and
find the photo of him and his son.
He ends up searching until he finds himself
underground in the dilapidated bathroom, polluted
by the bodies those tested and failed before
him, and clouded by Eric’s dark desperation
to locate his son.
I would guess that clouding is the reason
he momentarily lets his guard down when he
sees a pale hand at the edge of the bathtub,
perhaps thinking that Daniel was incapacitated
under the robes and pig mask.
In reality, it was Amanda, who injects him
with a powerful narcotic before he got the
chance to retaliate.
He next wakes up unarmed, with a chain around
his ankle tethering him to the pipe against
the wall.
The exact position Adam Stanheight had been
left in one year earlier.
Beside him he finds a tape, but unlike the
tapes he neglected to study during the previous
investigations of Jigsaw murders, this one
emanates the voice of Amanda Young, who condemns
him for framing her on a drug charge for which
she was not guilty.
Amanda has become a disciple of Jigsaw, and
Eric was her first test subject.
The final words of her tape say, “now you
are locked away, helpless and alone,” and
I find this to be an excellent example of
the punishment fitting the crime.
After putting so many guilty people behind
bars the easy way by fudging the evidence,
Eric would now be the one who is locked up
at the mercy of one of the people he has wronged.
As this is going on, time expires on Eric’s
game and the safe back at the steel plant
pops open, setting Daniel free after having
passed his test.
“Game over.”
With Jigsaw’s games, there is always a chance
for redemption, Amanda’s first game would
be no different.
He finds a flashlight and the hacksaw.
Looking around the room tells him what his
options are.
He sees the bodies of Xavier and Adam, and
the foot of Dr. Gordon.
He could choose to take the easy route and
spend the rest of his days in the bathroom,
or suffer through the pain of the trap and
hurt himself to escape.
Mathews gets the gun but it’s not loaded.
He’s unable to bring himself to cut his
foot off, but he finds the toilet lid and
uses it to crush the bone in his foot so he
can slide it out of the shackle.
I mean, I guess he did this because it’s
faster, but it doesn’t really seem less
painful at all.
It seems like it might be more painful.
Let me know in the comments what you would
prefer though.
He’s able to do what my cousin was unable
to after a hefty Thanksgiving dinner, and
make his way out of the bathroom.
But like my cousin, his suffering for that
evening did not end there, because Eric Matthews
would encounter an enemy on the other side
of that door.
Detective Matthews, after finding a pipe that
he uses as a crutch, continues to search for
his son Daniel, but what he finds instead
is his captor, Amanda and the two engage in
a physical altercation.
Matthews finds himself in position to take
her out before his broken foot becomes an
issue.
And then… he bites Amanda’s leg for some
reason.
“AHHHHH!”
"This is delicious!"
He gets a hold of Amanda and it seems his
old ways have not changed, because he tries
to beat the location of Daniel out of her.
She refuses to cooperate, and he’s about
to finish her off when she goes for his weak
foot and scrambles away.
Amanda is going to leave him like that, but
even in excruciating pain, Matthews true nature
shines through, and once again he can’t
just leave things be.
“You’re not Jigsaw *****. You hear me?
You’re nothing!”
Amanda comes back and we don’t see exactly
what happens after that, but Jigsaw would
later describe her actions as ‘leaving him
for dead’, so I’d say she mostly likely
attempted to kill him.
She even believes he's dead after those events,
but he’s actually able to survive somehow,
partially thanks to John Kramer going back
into the house and, as he puts it, cleaning
up Amanda’s mistake.
What happens next is not really in line with
the usual treatment of those who survive one
of Jigsaw’s games though.
Rather than immediately attempting to convert
Matthews into one of his followers, I think
John realizes that Amanda’s test did not
work on Matthews.
He had not rehabilitated like the other survivors
had, because he still tried to use force to
obtain the location of his son after escaping.
He's put into a cell down the hall in order
to reflect on his crimes, where he is given
an orange jumpsuit to bring him down to the
level of those he imprisoned.
He’s also given a foot brace and he’s
periodically fed some kind of goop through
a small slot.
Matthews is deliberately kept alive for the
next six months.
And he makes a furry little friend.
His confinement would end on April 28th, 2006,
when he’s taken to the Gideon Meat Packing
Plant for another game; another chance at
redemption.
He’s forced to barefoot on a large block
of ice with a noose around his neck as a timer
in the room counts down from 90 minutes.
As he takes in more of his surroundings, he
realizes that his fellow officer, Detective
Mark Hoffman is strapped down to a chair beside
him.
Another man walks into the room and pulls
a chain, which activates a contraption on
the ceiling above Matthews.
Eventually, after all he had been through,
he can’t take it anymore, and steps off
the ice block to try to off himself and end
his own suffering.
This gets the captor’s attention and he
picks Eric back up onto the ice block, explaining
that if he doesn’t weigh down the block,
the water melted off of the ice will run down
hill and electrocute his friend Detective
Hoffman.
Eric reluctantly decides to stay put, not
wanting to sacrifice the life of another just
so he can take the easy way out.
This part highlights the dynamic aspect of
Matthews character.
In his first game he’s made out to be selfish
and lazy, but he clearly does care about his
son, and I think the same can be said about
his comrade Hoffman.
With just under 20 minutes left on the timer,
Matthews pretends to lose consciousness, once
again drawing the attention of the captor,
but this time when he uses the close proximity
to attack him.
He holds his feet down, again, saving Hoffman
from electrocution, and tells Matthews, “I’m
not the one you gotta worry about, you understand
me?”
He divulges a little more information, telling
Matthews and Hoffman that there’s another
guy being tested, and if he passes, all of
them get to go free.
By making Eric stand on the ice block for
90 minutes, Jigsaw is testing his will to
live after being locked up for 6 months.
With the next phase of the game, he’s going
to test if Matthews learned anything in their
previous game -- if he’s learned to restrain
himself and let justice play out as Jigsaw
intends it to, or if he’s going to interfere
and take punishments into his own hands like
he did with the seven criminals and with Jigsaw
himself back at the Wilson Steel Plant.
To do this, Jigsaw has instructed the captor
to hand Eric a gun and a bullet.
With 19 minutes and six seconds remaining,
he gives Matthews the power to make his own
choice on what he wants to do with it.
When the timer gets below one minute, their
captor takes out a red button, which is supposed
to release them from their traps after the
time expires, as long as the fourth guy doesn’t
come through the door.
Matthews spots the other guy running up beyond
the translucent glass and tries to yell out
to warn him not to open it, but with just
two seconds left, the man, SWAT Officer Rigg
(who is another one of their fellow law enforcement
guys) charges the door to break it down.
As a last ditch effort, Matthews shoots the
glass, but this would not be enough to save
him.
Upon the opening of the door the contraption
him is released, and two huge ice blocks swing
down and crush his head, putting an end to
his long six months of suffering.
In the end, it seems that Eric Matthews story
is kind of a tragic one.
In the beginning he’s stubborn and does
things his way, but ultimately pays the price
for it, having to break his own foot and suffer
six months of solitary confinement to survive,
only to make it to a test where he suffered
even more, only to find out his life was in
the hands of Officer Rigg the whole time.
I think the argument can be made that by the
time Rigg came through that door, Matthews
actually had rehabilitated in a way.
He shows an act of selflessness by suffering
to keep Hoffman alive even when he no longer
wanted to go on, and he did manage to play
by the rules during his second game.
One thing I find interesting is that Jigsaw’s
victims usually do have some chance to redeem
themselves, but Matthews life seemed to be
entirely in the hands of Rigg.
The event of Rigg coming through the door
and Matthews firing the gun all happens at
once, so I’m wondering if maybe it’s possible
that Matthews was actually given a second chance.
Maybe there are actually two requirements
that must be met in order for the ice blocks
above his head to be released.
The first is obviously for Rigg to come through
the door before time expires.
As for the second, let’s say that there's a
microphone in the room somewhere use to detect
any loud noises above 140dB, so if Matthews
end up firing the gun, the device detects
that as the second requirement to release
the ice blocks.
Of course, this isn’t shown anywhere in
the movie, this is just an idea that I had,
but I think it falls more in line with Jigsaw’s
values.
So that ends the story of Eric Matthews, but
perhaps the Matthews name lives on… because
as far as we know, Matthews son Daniel is
still alive.
As we know, survivors of Jigsaw’s game often
become his followers, his disciples, the ones
to carry out his legacy.
Perhaps we will see Daniel Matthews again
in a future Saw movie… or perhaps we already
have.
At the end of Saw 7, spoiler alert if you
haven’t watched that far for some reason...
(And yes, I’m aware it’s called Saw 3D:
The Final Chapter or whatever; I prefer to
call it Saw 7) But yeah, at the end of Saw
7 we learn that Dr. Lawrence Gordon has been
helping Jigsaw behind the scenes all along,
and he captures Hoffman with the aid of two
masked henchman.
I know in the deleted scenes it turns out
to be these two cucks, but there’s a reason
that scenes are deleted, and intended storylines
do change as the Saw series plays out sometimes.
As far as I’m concerned, the identity of
these two is up in the air as far as the canon
goes for future installments.
In the past I’ve theorized that one of them
could be Logan Nelson, but I think another
possibility for the true identity of one of
these henchman could be… none other than…
Bradley Donovan -- I’ll see you all tomorrow
night!
Assuming we both survive!